we start today with the beginning of the
Dominion voting systems Fox News
defamation trial this is a trial that
could have such far-ranging impact and
we're going to be watching it
extraordinarily closely now the trial
was originally scheduled to start
yesterday there was the announcement
that there would be a delay and there
was the suspicion that the delay might
be
because Fox News wanted to settle the
case and prevent it from going to trial
whether or not that's what the cause of
the delay was the case is not being
settled and the trial is set to start
today CNBC reports Fox News and Dominion
trial kicks off with opening statements
in defamation suit Dominion has accused
Fox of intentionally and falsely blaming
it for president Donald Trump's loss to
Joe Biden by airing false claims that
the company rigged the 2020 election fox
has maintained the statements made about
Dominion on air are protected by the
First Amendment the case has led to the
release of troves of private messages
and testimony from Top Fox News figures
including Fox Corporation chairman
Rupert Murdoch and opinion host Tucker
Carlson so it was a couple different
things here that are of absolutely
critical importance first of all
the mere fact that Fox News is asserting
first amendment protection isn't unique
and it's really important to understand
that there are many circumstances in
which there is defamation alleged and as
a defense the first amendment is given
that doesn't make this case special it
doesn't particularly make it about
actually actual Free Speech this is a
case in which you are alleging
defamation meaning incorrect claims
knowingly made which are harmful to the
reputation in this case of dominion with
the Counterpoint that you can always
issue as a defense to defamation
uh the truth of the claims made if it
were true that Trump won in 2020 but
because of a rigging done involving
Dominion voting systems Joe Biden became
president if you could demonstrate that
then it would by definition not be
defamation and we're going to get back
to that in a moment we are going to see
among other things likely even more
documents and text messages and
Communications come out these are the
very Communications through which we
learned that there are some True
Believers on Fox news's staff including
people like Maria Bartiromo that there
are people on Fox News staff like Tucker
Carlson who despise Donald Trump
passionately was the word Tucker used to
describe his hate for Donald Trump
and on some level
this is sort of lose-lose for Fox Now
that it's gotten to this point and what
I mean by that is if Fox were to settle
they might avoid what now might be four
to six weeks of disastrous headlines as
more evidence comes out in the trial but
they would be to some degree admitting
guilt
and the alternative is well you don't
settle but you now have six weeks of
potentially disastrous headlines and at
the end of it you still might lose oh a
whole bunch of money and your reputation
reputation could be irreparably damaged
now I to get back to that a defense to
defamation is proving the facts Donald
Trump's suggestion which he posted uh
yesterday or the day before yesterday we
talked about it yesterday the truth
social truth essential was that fox
indeed do that and say hey it's not
defamation Trump really won Trump's idea
posted on Troth Central in all capital
letters was quote if Fox would finally
admit that there was large-scale
cheating and irregularities in the 2020
presidential election which would be a
good thing for them and for America the
case against them which should not have
existed at all would be greatly weakened
back up those Patriots at Fox instead of
throwing them under the bus and they are
right there is so much proof like Mass
ballots stuff nothing caught on
government cameras FBI colluding with
Twitter and Facebook State legislatures
not used Etc now there's a couple
interesting things about this first of
all as I mentioned defamation is a legal
term false statements harmful
to someone's reputation someone accuses
you of defamation one defense is proved
that what you said is true the problem
with Trump's idea other than the fact
that Trump didn't win the November of
2020 election and so you can't prove
something that's not true this
particular case is narrowly focused on
the allegedly defamatory statements made
about Dominion voting systems
involvement many of the things Trump is
talking about here ballot stuffing FBI
colluding with Twitter even if Fox tried
to prove that in this trial it wouldn't
be a useful defense because the
allegations in question that are
allegedly defamatory are the ones about
Dominion voting systems specifically
imagine the circus that that would be
though Fox News didn't defame anyone
because Trump did win and Dominion
voting systems did do whatever Mike
pillow says that they did with the
machines like imagine the circus that
that would become Side Story here that's
an important story that I do want to
mention as well
Angelo caruson
from Media Matters who we've interviewed
on the program
he has a really good Twitter thread
explaining an additional issue for Fox
News that could be disastrous and we'll
link to the Twitter thread in the
description uh for the YouTube video
where I'm talking about this Angelo
writes that uh parallel to this trial
Fox News is going to be renegotiating
and gearing up to renegotiate renewals
on Xfinity Charter and Cox these are
three different cable carriers Fox News
is the only commercial news and even you
could even go further than that uh
commercial TV channel that doesn't
actually need ads because they make a
lot of their money
because if you have a cable subscription
even if you don't like Fox News even if
you don't watch Fox News
some of your monthly bill goes directly
to Fox News behind ESPN Fox News is the
second most expensive channel on every
cable bill you can't change that
consider the situation where you now
have a beleaguered Fox News to put it
lightly
in the middle of a defamation trial
and they are going to have to go and
negotiate with these cable carriers and
say we want the same amount of money per
subscriber that you're giving us now or
we want even more money per subscriber
than you're giving us now and a lot of
these subscribers are going to look at
Fox potentially and say wait a second
it's not even really clear much of our
customer base wants your channel here's
evidence that not that many people are
watching and in addition you guys are
hugely damaged right now we don't even
know what the future is of Fox News the
last thing we're going to do is commit
to paying however many dollars a month
you want us to pay this is a parallel
story to the Dominion lawsuit that could
be a disaster for Fox News and we're
going to be watching it as well the
trial will not be televised many people
writing to me saying David will it will
it be streamed live it will not but
there will be reporters in the courtroom
and we are going to get daily updates
let's see how the first day goes one of
our sponsors is betterhelp I am a huge
believer in therapy let's say you've
been thinking for a while about getting
into therapy you know it's the right
move you have things you'd like to talk
to someone about there is no better time
than the present but you don't have to
drive across town every week and sit in
a waiting room because of better help
better help is the world's largest
therapy service it's 100 online with
better help you can tap into a network
of over 25
000 licensed and experienced therapists
specializing in a wide range of issues
you answer a few questions about
yourself and better help will match you
with a therapist based on your specific
needs and preferences the sessions can
be on the phone video call chat anytime
anywhere from your couch at home from
your office at work and if your
therapist isn't the right fit you can
switch anytime at no charge my audience
gets 10 percent off your first month at
betterhelp.com Pacman the link is down
below